let's start here's from breitbart it
says
former president donald trump endorsed
celebrity doctor
um dr oz in pennsylvania's u.s senate
race on saturday after his initial pick
sean parnell dropped out amid a
contentious custody battle with his with
his estranged wife last fall trump said
his endorsement of oz is all about
winning elections in order to stop the
radical left maniacs from destroying our
country
um
trump said in a statement the great
commonwealth of pennsylvania has a
tremendous opportunity to save america
by electing the brilliant and well-known
dr mehmet oz for the united states
senate i have known dr oz for many years
as as have many others even if only
through his various uh through his very
successful television show trump touted
the thousands of life-saving heart
operations oz has performed throughout
his medical career
and the eight new york times best
sellers he authored
trump also pointed to oz's pro-life
views right and his strength on the
border election fraud in the military as
reasons for his endorsement trump said
dr oz is pro-life very strong on crime
the border election fraud our great
military and our vets tax cuts that will
always fight for and support our under
siege second amendment he will ensure
america will become energy independent
again dr oz also passionately believes
in high quality education and protecting
parent involvement throughout the
process um okay
none of that just so you know none of
that is remotely true at all dr oz
is and has always been pro-abortion
anti-gun
he's spoken about this publicly many
times now maybe when he started running
for for senate
he experienced the conversion on all of
these issues all at once but that's
going to make you a little bit skeptical
i mean some i don't know how old dr oz
is he's his let's say his mid-60s at
least
so guy in his mid-60s has a certain
point of view for his entire life
and then decides to run for office as a
republican and all at once magically
look at that he's a he has it's a it's a
road to damascus moment
what a coincidence
no dr oz is without a doubt a full-on
leftist not just
not just uh like lien's liberal
establishment republican type he is a
leftist and i'll play a video in a
second that proves this he is a far left
leftist
he is actually about as far left as you
can be he's on the cutting edge of
leftism right now or or damn near it at
least
and uh
i mean we don't even
there are so many problems with dr oz we
don't even need to mention the fact that
he's not at all qualified to be senator
the fact that he was a tv doctor for 20
years i don't see i don't really see the
correlation between that and being an
effective senator then again senators
don't really do much anyway so i guess
anyone could be qualified for so that's
not even that's not my problem with him
my problem is that he is a far
left leftist
that's my issue
that donald trump decided to endorse now
um
i've heard over the weekend many
for donald trump because there are
people
on the right lots of people on the right
who are always ready and eager to make
excuses for donald trump because we've
decided
um and this has been the case for ever
since trump was on the scene as a
political figure
it's been decided generally speaking by
the right that trump is never
responsible for anything that he does
it's all like any any mistake is always
somebody else's fault
and so the excuse that i'm hearing from
trump is that oh it's his advisors ah
those those damned advisors again
well maybe we should start asking first
of all if it is his advisor's fault why
is he so terrible at hiring advisors and
second of all is he not capable of
analyzing these things for himself and
saying that dr oz i mean it took me five
minutes
to discover that dr oz is a leftist
and i haven't known him for my entire
life or i haven't known him for years
like trump has you know if you lie awake
tossing and turning at night not able to
sleep it may be the fact that our
society is collapsing all around us or
it might just be that you have the wrong
mattress this is why you need helix
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made from somebody else
because helix has everything with helix
you're getting a mattress that will that
you know will be perfect for the way
that you sleep because it's custom made
just for you they have soft medium and
firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains and
we even have a helix plus mattress for
plus size sleepers so if you're looking
for a mattress you take the quiz you
order the mattress that you're matched
to and the mattress comes right to your
door shipped for free it's that easy you
don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again just go to
helixsleep.comwalsh
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life guaranteed they have
a 10-year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will love it you have to
worry about that helix even has a
financing options and flexible payment
plans so a great night's sleep is never
far away helix is offering up to 200 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
so i don't buy that excuse i also don't
buy the excuse that um
that well the other guy you know the
other people there there are no good
candidates in the race right now for
senate on the republican side in
pennsylvania and they're all a bunch of
establishment mild toast types and so
you know there's there there is no good
option that i can believe
i certainly believe that so
but if that's the case then either you
endorse nobody
or if you are going to endorse dr oz for
some reason which i don't know why you
would because there's no way he's the
best
i don't care who the other guys are
there's no way that dr oz is better than
them
because you can't get much worse
but if you are going to do it then just
say
that he's the lesser of two evils that
he like he's not great but then again
uh you know he's he's more likely to win
in the general whatever your argument is
just be honest about it don't try to put
him forward as a pro-life champion
so if you want to know what dr oz is all
about
uh let's go back to one of his and this
is the great thing about a guy who's
been on tv forever is that he's
you could just go and watch the tape
he's he has addressed all of these
issues extensively
in interviews and on his own show and
he's made his views very clear
so this is from i believe several years
ago in fact
so dr oz before it was
as popular as it is now on the left
to promote trans kids
before that
doctor that's why i said he's on the
cutting edge of leftism
here he was a few years ago on a show
singing the praises of
childhood transgenderism watch
what if your son told you he was meant
to be a she she always knew that she is
a girl would you let your child become
the opposite sex talk to me about why i
decide to have a double mastectomy at
age 14. inside the lives of transgender
kids
this show is going to be controversial
for a lot of people challenging your
beliefs about what it means to be male
or female the word you'll hear today is
transgender
transgender it describes people who sex
on the outside doesn't match who they
are on the inside
now imagine your child is transgender
what would you do
our lives as parents are first defined
by the words it's a girl or it's a boy
could you make a decision to let your
child live as the other sex even alter
their body
it's an area of intense debate today
you'll meet families coping with this
astonishing reality
what does it mean to be a boy
what does it mean to be a girl
those two simple questions are
infinitely complex and gut wrenching for
parents of
[Music]
eight-year-old josie was born joseph
physically she's a boy but from the time
she could talk josie knew she was a girl
it doesn't get any better by the way you
can see the entire episode you can
stomach it which is on youtube right now
and and lest you try to make any excuses
for dr oz and say well he just talked
about the issue
he's taken an objective
view of it well even that would be
terrible because you can't take an
objective view of children being
sexually abused which is what this is
there's no there's no well you know
these kids are being sexually abused but
let's let's think of it objectively um
that is already terrible
but that's not even what he's doing i
mean it's very clear in the episode that
he is promoting this he is he is
legitimizing and validating it using
his
doctor label to validate this stuff
um
and that's very it's very effective in a
lot of people's minds i mean there are a
lot of people who
for years have been sitting around
watching these these um these kinds of
people on on tv
and they see this stuff promoted and
they think well hey
if dr oz says it's fine or that it's
valid then it must be
he says that uh well what does it mean
to be a boy
uh it's it's infinitely complex it's not
complex actually it's not complex at all
it's very simple
and you know you must know that as a
medical professional
so you watch that you think like this
guy
is running for senate as a republican
and he just got an endorsement from the
previous republican president
it's the republican party is in shambles
in shambles right now
but when when that i mean
if that becomes accepted
if that becomes fully mainstream
accepted on the right or among
republicans then it is over and i mean
it it's it's done it's over
um because that is
that has to be a deal breaker i don't we
could get into his positions on abortion
gun rights i mean all of it is bad but
if you're endorsing trans children the
concept of there being such a thing as a
trans child
um that has to be
the where the line is drawn deal breaker
that's it
and if it's not and if we let that
become the standard in the republican
party
then it's it's done it's over
and then you have democrats and then
other side you have democrats and that's
all that there is
and i know you might say that we're
already in that position where you've
got the democrat party than the democrat
light party
i would say that we're we're not there
yet
there is a battle within the republican
party right now over you know it's a
kind of a civil war it really depends on
on who wins that battle
because ron desantis
is also a republican and he obviously is
not endorsing transgenderism in children
so you've got two sides the two sides of
the public party kind of battling it out
right now
and if the side that wants to
mainstream this kind of stuff gender
ideology if they win
then it's done
politically it's done
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated